what's going on guys there's a little
movie hitting theaters this week called
monster trucks haven't heard of it well
join the club
in fact the studio releasing it took
what's called a write-off on the film
which means they predicted that the
movie was going to crap the bed at the
box office and that got us thinking what
are the biggest box-office bombs of all
time we're gonna talk about that today
and we have a panel who itself is the
bomb first off I'd like to welcome back
the host of FX movie download and she is
the Diane Sawyer screen junkies news
welcome back Sasha pearl raver exhale
have excited to talk about big turds oh
yeah some big stinking box-office turn
it's better to do it come on now yes
there is the host of super animation
game time on geek and sundry and you
know from the top ten list and you can
see him on Collider movie talk every
Friday Jon Roco welcome to this thank
you I mean I was in military for eight
years so I know about bombs let's make
this happen let's talk about do it so
right out of the gate let's talk about
the three biggest bombs of all time and
these numbers are adjusted for inflation
so we're however you stack it these are
the biggest losers first off okay a 1995
pirate adventure starring Geena Davis
cutthroat island what a terrible move
that thing is I mean pirates already is
a difficult subject will be about to
crash and burn as bad as they did on
this film water is dangerous yes what is
this have to seek my treasure
let's finish this let's get into these
numbers here
these are 1995 numbers but even an idiot
like me can tell that these are terrible
cost 98 million made eighteen point
three million and if take that the loss
adjusted for inflation a hundred and
forty million dollars well the rule is
what you have to make two-and-a-half
times the original budget of the film to
make to see a profit and this is an
event this is making like almost four
and a half times less than what it
started out MIT it started out with and
here's the thing is whenever we get
these budget numbers they never talk
about marketing marketing is such a huge
amount of the cost of movie they don't
factor that in that could be another
fifty million that they're not even
accounting for yeah international
marketing as well moving on the second
biggest bomb adjusted for inflation of
all time tighten a II the production
budget was between 75 and 90 million it
grossed thirty six point eight million
estimated loss adjusted for inflation a
hundred and thirty nine million dollars
you have to try so hard when you have a
family movie to not bring people in well
once again this may be a stay film that
sank the studio Fox Animation Studios
closed after it got released you know it
was the last film they released so maybe
they're like yeah we're no good at this
we're gonna stop here yeah we're gonna
give up the lease I don't remember this
movie at all oh okay like I have no
recollection of it I eat like I think
there was like a Martian planet it was
Matt Damon's prequel to the Marsha
really yeah I do you remember anything
about it was more like a prequel to Mars
Needs Moms as far as box-office uh-huh
and then the third biggest bomb of all
time 2002 s Pluto Nash budget a hundred
million estimated gross 7.1 million oh
and the loss adjusted for inflation one
hundred and twenty eight mil cool 128 oh
yeah look at bad look at me it's amazing
to me because Eddie has so many bombs on
his resume but people still keep giving
him a shot because of the goodwill from
the 80s and the stuff you did with Mulan
and the stuff he's done with Shrek with
donkey obviously like he still keeps
coming people still want a Nutty
Professor like Good Sam is like
Dreamgirls and be good
right these grand dream girls right then
yes when he does a standalone where he
has his own church last year was true
Sasha and John you each came in with a
couple of films that you want to talk
about just bombs that really oh that
hurt you that struck you to the core
Sasha why don't you uh well here I have
one that struck me to the core on so
many different levels it was terrible it
was just unnecessary and then it bombed
and it made me feel a little better but
I almost wish it had done worse and that
movie has been her the third remake of
Ben Hur yeah just utterly unnecessary
timur bekmambetov basically taking like
a gopro and throwing a volleyball down
like a horse racing it just made no
sense there was nothing about it that
was redeemable there was no reason to
make it but it made what 94 million and
the budget was a hundred yeah I feel
like that movie deserves to have made
like fourteen million and real quick the
stats on Ben Hur production budget 100
million it made 94 million and the
estimated loss adjusted for inflation
between 75 and 122 million so I guess
that's what the marketing and marketing
promotion and everything else but it
also just lost so much goodwill so we've
talked about some directors earlier of
the Wachowski siblings had a little
offering recently called Jupiter
ascending production budget was 176
million international gross 184
estimated loss justa for inflation
88 to 121 million and almost an Oscar if
this had come out a little bit earlier I
think Redmayne does not win the Oscar
Eddie is so bad it's bad I think if
enough audience had seen this before the
vote happened he'd had been sunk and I
think that's why the studio waited or he
pushed them to wait until the last
minute to release it no yes an act
John why don't you throw one out there
yeah I would throw in here Green Lantern
that was one that I was so excited they
were going to do and then they cast Ryan
Reynolds and I love Ryan I'm a fan of
Ryan Reynolds I love Van Wilder I love
just friends one of my closet favorite
Christmas movies and they put him in Hal
Jordan he is not Hal Jordan he is Wally
West and when you started to see the
jokey things that he does which he did
great in Deadpool you saw it as Hal
Jordan like no Hal Jordans a cocky pilot
who doesn't give zero F's about anybody
and when you put him in a situation like
Ryan it doesn't work I know right
Green Lantern 2011 budget 200 million
gross 220 million and the estimated loss
adjusted for inflation 73 to 96 million
give or take I would argue that it was
more of a loss because the potential of
hundreds of millions of dollars they
could have made would it was was
astronomical and so the loss I think
although it says 73 to 96 I think it's
probably 3 or 400 million and one
because it was it would've been a
franchise yeah it would've had a
franchise it could have grown and grown
and it really is something where they're
still I think trying to rebuild you want
to throw out another one there Sasha uh
let's have a pan oh boy do we have yeah
do we have to we'll talk about it
briefly hahaha well especially I feel
like this came up for me in my head
because I also just watched Emerald City
was just like that's actually getting
good ratings but man that just sucks
okay it's a similar thing it's like this
is a great idea it's a reimagining of
Peter Pan
hey go let's throw in smells like teen
spirit cuz for nothing
[Applause]
so yeah so bad that Nirvana scene it's
just like nails on a chalkboard the
thing that I do appreciate is all movies
we're talking about really did deserved
about yeah but these are all really
terrible movies that I'm grateful
audiences didn't suffer through on mass
production budget 150 million I don't
even know what these numbers mean that
is so much I am I trow fathoming that
amount of money gross 128 point 4
million estimated lost adjusted for
inflation with everything all told 94 to
152 million dollars Sasha I know you got
one more for us this one this one is
just a doozy of filmmaking mm-hmm have
you guys ever seen Battlefield Earth
I've not seen Battlefield Earth so this
is one of those like rent for home so
that you can stand up and scream on your
couch looks like Tom Cruise would that
was a Scientology shout-out right there
this was John Travolta's passion project
yes he wanted to make this movie which
is based on an l ron Hubbard Nivelle
this was basically this passion project
that he wanted to do for years and
nobody would make it because it's
horribly written it's a terrible
terrible movie but there was this
company back in like the 90s 80s and 90s
that was financing celebrity passion
projects this sunk that business it is
the nadir of John Travolta's career and
this is like post Pulp Fiction
this is like pose get shorty he was at a
point where he could do whatever he
wanted he was like I want to make a
Scientology propaganda piece my
informants tell me that the first order
of business is to separate you from your
head the production budget on
Battlefield Earth was somewhere between
73 to 103 million it grossed
29.7 million and adjusted for inflation
they took a 102 million dollar loss
almost the entire production budget yes
Wow crazy and John you've got one more
stinker Rudy yeah here another remake
which Sasha had brought up Ben Hur
Poseidon which is a remake of one of the
great disaster movies of the 70s the
Poseidon Adventure with Gene Hackman
and Ernest Borgnine Shelley Winters
Edward Albert so many great actors in
that film
what a great enjoyable film and then
they decide to remake it call it beside
and perk or rustle in it Richard
Dreyfuss as a guy who wants to kill
himself but all of a sudden wants to
live after he wants to kill himself
that's what rivals in real life and you
think well Richard Dreyfuss going back
to the water like you did in Jaws isn't
this gonna work or what about Bob this
is gonna work
water is dangerous yeah yeah it is so
easy cutthroat island poseidon it is
Waterworld it is very easy to make a bad
movie you can argue tight maybe because
it's essentially a pirate film in space
you can argue it is very easy to set
sail for box-office gold and then sink
yeah uh Wow are there any bombs that we
left off this list that you're like oh
why aren't they talking about this one
please let us know in the comments
section below
we want to know what you're thinking oh
I got a thank this dream team you guys
again are the bomb personified Oh Sasha
tell us where we can find you
uh you can find me at Sasha Pearl River
on Twitter and Instagram here with
screen boogies news and hosting ethics
movie download every Friday night
Jon Roca and you guys can always find me
at the Roku says on Twitter on Instagram
UCB every Friday on Collider movie talk
every Wednesday 1:00 p.m. on geek and
sundry's Church channel with super
animation game time with Yuri Lowenthal
and then possibly the top ten show
there's rumors about it coming back
we'll see what happens you see what
happens we'll stay tuned for that guys I
want to thank you so much for being here
I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on Twitter bye
bye hey guys did you know that this end
card works with your phone now I know
right click the boxes below to watch
more screen junkies videos and click the
screen junkies logo to subscribe and get
this show honest trailers movie fights
and more